Guten Morgen, Thomas. Fühlst du dich neutral.
Ich bin immer neutral.
Lokbuchnetzpolitik Ausgabe einhundertundneunzehn und äh ihr hört es schon
die nutzt es immer noch im Urlaub und entspannt sich und äh während er das tut, äh nutze ich die Gelegenheit hier die ganzen ähm.
Stammgäste, ne äh eigentlich schon äh nahezu Teammitglieder von Logbuch Netzpolitik mal wieder so aus der Versenkung herauszuholen. Ja und wenn wir schon lange nicht mehr hatten, ist Thomas. Thomas Luniger, hallo Thomas.
Hallo. Ja, ich darf ja nicht fehlen meine Wette mit Andre. Wir haben letztens rausgefunden, es steht acht acht und mit heute neun acht. Ich liege wieder in Führung.
Ja, genau, so ein bisschen kann nicht schaden, auch im mittelspolitischen Bereich,
Ja, wir hatten ja ähm das letzte Mal äh, warte mal, vorhin hatte ich's schon rausgerutscht, habe ich schon wieder vergessen, welche Folge das war, aber ist schon eine Weile her. Achtundneunzig oder so.
Achtundneunzig am.
Genau. Das war im April und da äh war ja gerade eine ganze Menge passiert, wer es nicht gehört hat und auch nicht mehr sonstwie erinnert, da warst du ja mächtig unter Strom im.
Gemeinsam mit Edri beziehungsweise der war halt eher so mit den Abgeordneten des
europäischen Parlaments und ihr habt halt alle alles in Bewegung gesetzt, um die Abstimmung über Netzneutralität ins ähm Positive zu verändern, was euch ja am Ende auch gelungen ist,
wohlgemerkt, das alte Parlament, das jetzt nicht mehr so in der Form Betrieb ist.
Ja, wir haben uns da ja zusammengesetzt und gleich am Tag, nachdem das Plenum des Europaparlaments äh sich für Netzzentralität ausgesprochen hat
ähm gleich wieder drüber geredet, was ähm was passiert ist und wie wir es geschafft haben, da das Ruder rumzureißen.
Ähm und ja, wir haben jetzt ein neues Parlament, das haben sich auch viele von den handelnden Personen geändert, ähm nicht alle, so zumindest äh zum Beispiel Pilare Castillio, die Berichterstatterin für das Dossier ist immer noch dieselbe.
Haben sich geändert, weil sie nicht mehr reingekommen sind äh ins Europaparlament. Aber ähm so wichtig ist das gar nicht, weil jetzt das Parlament sowieso noch an die letzte Abstimmung gebunden ist. Also,
das, was in der ersten Lesung am dritten April beschlossen wurde, das ist die offizielle Position des Parlaments, an die sich jetzt auch alle,
ähm Verhandler fürs Parlament halten müssen. Die große Frage ist aber eher so der Rat und wie sich die achtundzwanzig Mitgliedsstaaten positionieren werden.
Und natürlich auch für die neue Kommission sich da äh aufstellen wird, da ist ja auch noch nicht ganz raus, wie es aussehen wird, obwohl das sich jetzt, glaube ich, abzeichnet, ich weiß nicht, ist das neue ist die neue Kommission jetzt schon angenommen worden?
Morgen.
Zweiundzwanzigsten Oktober sollte da irgendwie so mal einer der Filialen Abstimmungen sein. Ich weiß nicht, ob das dann noch ins Plenum muss oder ob da schon das Plenum ist, aber im Grunde ist es mehr oder weniger durch. Also ich erwarte da jetzt keine großen Änderungen mehr.
Personell zumindest. Ähm dann ist natürlich auch noch die Frage, was machen die sich für Arbeitspakete aus? Ähm wie wichtig werden gewisse Dinge eingeschätzt? Und das ist dann natürlich auch für uns wichtig, wenn's um Datenschutz und Netzzentralität.
Ja. Das heißt, wir können uns da auf jeden Fall,
einstellen auf unter anderem Günther Oettinger, der ja so für die digitale Wirtschaft jetzt zuständig sein soll, was auch immer das letztlich ähm heißen soll,
Und ähm vielleicht noch ein bisschen äh wichtiger. Äh jetzt habe ich den Namen gerade nicht mehr parat. Der.
Zweite Kommissar ähm wie heißt der nochmal? Anten.
Ähm Ansens, ähm ja Moment, da muss ich auch nachschauen.
Ja, den Namen müssen wir noch ein bisschen besser draufkriegen, ne.
Ja, ich war nur bei dem äh von von Oettinger und von Maimström ähm aber ihn habe ich nicht gesehen.
Er macht aber auf jeden Fall den besseren Eindruck.
Ja, ja, der hat sich ja auch gleich mit dieser Asgard-Kampagne im Internet beliebt gemacht, dass er mit einem Hashtag äh Fragen entgegengenommen hat.
Ähm das das hat sehr gut funktioniert, so als kleiner Werbekampagne für ihn und ja, auch Bürgerbeteiligung, was den Leuten da im Europaparlament ja immer ein Anliegen ist.
Ja, kann man natürlich jetzt äh als PR-Kampagne äh kritisieren, wird sicherlich auch getan. Auf der anderen Seite äh kann man auch feststellen, immerhin ähm geschieht das halt auch mal, aber am Ende, welche Politik dabei rauskommt, lässt sich, glaube ich, derzeit noch nicht so richtig.
Ähm.
Ablesen aus der ganzen Sache, aber bevor wir auf die ganzen Nachrichten äh kommen und auch gleich das Thema Netzneutralität noch mal ein weiteres Mal aufgreifen wollen, wollte ich nochmal kurz
nachhaken. Weiß nicht, wie lange warst du letzten Endes in Europa, äh also in in ist noch Brüssel.
Ähm ich war ähm so ein bisschen mehr als drei Monate bei,
Ähm und da eben explizit schon immer begrenzt auf die heiße Phase von der Netzzentralitätsverordnung
Und als die dann ähm durch war und im Plenum beschlossen, war auch klar, ich gehe wieder zurück nach Wien. Ähm und das habe ich dann auch gemacht und hier mein, mein Studium abgeschlossen. Ich studiere ja
ähm Anthropologie oder was bei euch Ethnologie ist,
Ja, das habe ich gemacht, dann war ich auch auf Urlaub in Asien und ähm ja, jetzt bin ich seit August wieder wieder hier in Wien und ähm,
auch gleich äh einen neuen Job angenommen, aber darüber reden wir später.
Genau, das werden wir machen. Ja und dann warst du vor allem vor ein paar Tagen auch in Berlin
Da gab's nämlich eine kleine Veranstaltung, auf die wir vielleicht auch nochmal kurz zurückblicken wollen, nachdem wir sie vorher auch äh angekündigt hatten, nämlich zehn Jahre Netzpolitik Punkt ORG als Konferenz und später dann auch als Party. Schönes Ding, wie ich fand, war sehr ähm cosy, mal auch vor allem
Leute ähm also nur Leute zu treffen, die zwangsläufig irgendwie so aus dem Netz politischen Aktivismus, Umfeld,
Unterstützerkreis herauskamen. Also anders ist, als zum Beispiel äh als bei der Republika, wo es ja dann doch eher eine Medien,
Konferenz mit ne, starker Internetbetonung natürlich äh hat, wo auch Netzpolitische Aspekte eine große Rolle spielen.
Aber es eben nur ein Teil davon ist, hatte man jetzt hier ähm wirklich mal so den Eindruck, alle beisammen zu haben. Das fand ich eigentlich ganz nett.
Ja, also mir hat die Veranstaltung auch wahnsinnig gefallen. Ähm hauptsächlich inhaltlich, weil es waren ja auch ähm immer sehr kurze Vorträge, also alle hatten nur zwanzig Minuten Zeit für ihr Thema.
Und dadurch äh äh hatte das diesen schönen Nebeneffekt, dass alle irgendwie die Einführung weggelassen haben und sich wirklich nur so ins Thema gestürzt,
und deswegen war ähm das auch sehr, sehr high Level intellektuell, sehr anspruchsvoll, ähm irrsinnig viele intelligente Leute auf einem Haufen noch dazu in einer Location, die Irrsinn nicht passend war.
Für Netzpolitikerort, also für den Blog und für die Leute, die das machen ähm und das das war schon ein wirklich schöner Geburtstag.
Ja und vor allem, was sie äh immer wieder betonen möchte, Single-Track.
Ja, also ich habe immer so bin auf so vielen Veranstaltungen, die dann immer der Meinung sind, ja, da müssen wir ganz viel machen, wir müssen ganz viel machen und dann hat man einfach das Problem,
einfach dann Dinge einfach auch parallel stattfinden. Das gab's hier nicht. Hier gibt's einfach nur einen Trick, ein Tag, ein Trick und.
Gut, man kann dann immer noch schwänzen, aber wenn man halt irgendwie da sitzt und zuhört, dann,
kriegen quasi alle auch in etwa dieselbe Erzählung mit, was natürlich auch eine ganz andere Diskussions
Basis ist für die Zeit danach. Und ich denke, dass das einen sehr effizientes Format ist, was man ähm auch häufiger machen kann, wer darüber nachdenkt, irgendwas zu thematisieren.
Nicht zu sehr verlieren in zu viel Angebot und alles abdecken wollen, lieber mal so ein bisschen Fokus. Also ich finde das sehr schön und ich habe so ein bisschen den Eindruck, elf Jahre Nutz,
Politik org, kann man dann wahrscheinlich auch gleich nochmal nachfeiern. Das war irgendwie so ein,
Ding, wo man das Gefühl hat, ja das könnte eigentlich auch so als jährlicher Ankerpunkt durchaus noch der Konferenzlandschaft hinzugefügt werden können. Aber das wissen wir nicht und äh ist auch noch nicht absehbar und wahrscheinlich fällt jetzt irgendjemand gerade bei Netz Politik org vor Schreck nach hinten.
Es wurde ja dann auch gleich äh passend geadelt, ja, also hier Peter Altmaier, Bundes äh Kanzleramtschef.
Ehemaliger Umweltminister und äh erster gefühlt erster Twitter äh Minister ähm der Bundesrepublik Deutschland
war ja etwas ungehalten, weil äh da eben so viele Dokumente gelegt wurden aus seinen Ministerien
und äh da ging's vor allem um die Veröffentlichung äh rund um Alconal, also das.
Beziehungsweise durchreichen, abgehörter Daten des BNDs zur äh NSA und
ja, wie wir hier auch schon mal diskutiert haben, hat das ja für allerlei Thermik gesorgt. Wie groß die Thermik ist, äh machte sich dann eben ganz gut an seiner Reaktion fest, wo dann eben in so einem.
Eigentlich nicht öffentlich ist, aber der dann öffentlich wurde und auch von der Politik auch veröffentlicht wurde
Rundumschlag gegen die Medien gemacht hat, was die sich dann alles einfallen lassen würden. Na ja und dann war dann halt Netzpolitik Org auch mit dabei, also passend zum zehn Jahre Geburtstagsparty dann eben auch die offizielle Adelung, das äh Netzpolitik Org hier ausreichend gefährlich zu sein scheint.
Ja, gleich mit Strafanzeige drohen, was natürlich in einem NSE-Untersuchungsausschuss, der nur dadurch zustande kam, dass jemand Dokumente geliebt hat
äh nicht einer gewissen Komik entbehrt
Ähm und äh das habt ihr auch äh in der letzten Folge mit andere schon ähm ausführlich behandelt, ähm dass da auf einmal die Polizei hinter den Medien steht, wenn sie aus dem Parlament berichten wollen
wirft natürlich grundsätzlich die Frage auf, äh in welchem Umfeld kann man sich denn überhaupt mit der Kontrolle von Geheimdiensten auch beschäftigen?
Also weil grade diese Einschüchterung die die wird hier einfach die passiert gerade. Also ich glaube schon, dass das in der Form wie es jetzt in den letzten Wochen publik wurde Einfluss hat
auf gewisse Medien oder Leute, die sich dann vielleicht nicht so viel ähm Meinung sagen, trauen zu dem, was da im Parlament diskutiert wird.
Ja, das kann gut sein.
Ja, kommen wir zum Thema Netzneutralität, wo wir ja, wie wir schon eingangs erwähnt haben, das war ja quasi sein letztes großes Ding auf EU-Ebene, aber jetzt hier auch passend zu unserem Zusammentreffen hier, äh gibt's ja auch,
Neuigkeiten. Also vielleicht kannst du mal so ein bisschen ähm zusammenfassen. Du hast es ja auch oft zehn Jahre Netzpolitik Org, also hast du ja auch einen Vortrag gehalten, nämlich genau da drüber, über äh Update eine Netzneutralität. Ich musste leider
die Veranstaltung genau zu dem Zeitpunkt verlassen wo du deinen Talk gehalten hast, von daher bin ich jetzt auch selber noch nicht so ganz up to date, aber vielleicht kannst du ja für uns mal so die Essenz hier nochmal
schildern.
Ja, also da der Vortrag war schon ein bisschen Management Summery, ähm weil eben nur zwanzig Minuten. Ich versuche, ihn jetzt noch irgendwie weiter zu zu destillieren, aber
die äh Aufzeichnung sollte,
ähm heute am einundzwanzigsten Oktober oder morgen am Mittwoch schon online sein. Und an sich äh ging's mir halt einfach drum, so all das nachzuzeichnen, was jetzt nach der Abstimmung im Europaparlament passiert
ist. Also eben, dass wir da neue Personen haben, ähm wer die sind und und mit wem wir vielleicht irgendwie guter
besser oder schlechter reden können als Zivilgesellschaft. Und dann hat ganz viel auch über den Rat zu sprechen, weil das ist noch so.
Eine der Achillesversen ähm der netzpolitischen Bewegung. Wir sind eigentlich recht gut da drin ähm mit der Kommission zu sprechen. Da gibt's inzwischen teils Ansprechpart
im Parlament haben wir eigentlich auch unseren Weg gefunden ähm uns einzumischen, aber wenn's in den Rat geht und wenn die Staaten miteinander reden, dann sind wir sehr schlecht. Da haben wir einfach
ganz wenig Erfolge, auf die wir verweisen können und wenig Weg gefunden mit so Ministeriumsleuten, die alle,
keine Verantwortung haben, die ja gar nicht gewählt sind, die sich oft auch nicht dem Parlamenten verantworten müssen,
die dann äh europäisch koordiniert Druck auszuüben, das ist noch so eine Herausforderung.
Genau, vielleicht aber äh vielleicht noch mal kurz zur Verdeutlichung, weil ich glaube, das ist nicht jedem immer so unbedingt klar, ne, wie diese dieses Dreigestirn funktioniert, also das Parlament ist klar, das wird gewählt, äh durch die Europawahlen, wie jüngst eben wieder geschehen. Die Kommission
dann äh vom Kommissions äh vom Kommissionspräsidenten
denen man sich äh geeinigt hat, äh vorgestellt und dann auch vom Parlament abgelegt. Das findet jetzt gerade statt. Das sind quasi so die gewählten und so quasi teilegitimiert,
Organe und dazu kommt eben noch der Rat und es ist eben nichts anderes als die Summe aller europäischen Regierungen oder aller EU-Regierungen, sprich
Hier sind es quasi die abgesandten äh der jeweiligen Regierung,
beziehungsweise eben auch die Regierung selbst, die hier quasi ihr direktes Nationales Interesse im Gesetzesprozess der EU verankert.
Genau und die müssen halt auch zustimmen, ohne dieses Gremium kann man kein europäisches Gesetz machen und ähm das vielleicht ein bisschen konkret zu machen, die handelnden Personen sind dort.
Bei kleinen Ländern oft aus den ständigen Vertretungen in Brüssel. Ähm das sind dann einzelne Leute, die sich mit zwei, vier, fünf, sieben Dossiers gleichzeitig beschäftigen müssen und dementsprechend oberflächlich nur das Ganze behandeln können.
Größeren Staaten mit mehr Ressourcen sind das dann durchaus auch gleich mehrere Leute
die dort am Tisch sitzen und diese Tische teilen sich auch auf, man hat so Arbeitstreffen, wo die Ministeriumsleute über das Inhaltliche sprechen, da wird dann auch wirklich im Text gearbeitet und dann hat man so Ministertreffen,
zum Beispiel Telekom Minister,
also Infrastruktur, Wirtschaftsminister zusammenkommen und dann alle achtundzwanzig ähm sich in einer großen Sitzung halt äh über die politische Ausrichtung einig werden.
Und ähm beides zusammen braucht man halt eben, um eine Position im Rat zu finden. Ähm und und um jetzt auf die Netzautralität zu kommen, da schaut's halt so aus, dass.
Das Ganze Dossier wie das damals vorgestellt hat so ein bissel schwammig war, also es gibt mehrere Dinge die den Staaten nicht so gefallen an diesem Telekom Binnenmarkt
Verordnungsvorschlag. Dadurch äh deswegen sind doch einige Sachen schon komplett weggefallen. Also es wird jetzt zum Beispiel nicht mehr drüber geredet, dass man groß Spektren vereinheitlich.
Dass es äh eine vereinheitliche Regulierung im Telekombereich geben soll, die über die Grenzen hinweg,
ähm sondern worauf man sich jetzt wirklich konzentriert, ist Roaming und Netzneutralität.
Und ähm es gibt so grob zwei Szenarien äh in welche Richtung das gehen könnte. Ähm Szenarien Nummer eins ist, dass,
man wirklich nur eine Miniverordnung macht, die eigentlich nur Netzertralität beinhaltet und vielleicht Roaming?
Weil man eben so über den Rest sich sowieso nicht einig wird und das auch gar nicht als notwendig erachtet, da jetzt groß neue Gesetze zu verabschieden.
Und ähm da haben wir natürlich dann die Situation, dass wenn wirklich nur Netznetralität kommt, dann gibt's eine gute Chance, dass das dann wenigstens eine starke ist, weil nur eine schwache Netzzentralität.
Ähm ist hat wenig Überlebenschancen, weil's dann auch nur Kritiker gibt. Ich meine, die Telkos würden sich natürlich wünschen, dass es Lachse gibt.
Damit haben sie das ganze Problem Netznetralität in Europa gelöst, ein für alle Mal.
Ja aber dann stünde quasi die komplette Verordnung mehr oder weniger direkt im Gegensatz oder zumindest im Konflikt mit dem mit der Entscheidung, wie ist das Parlament ja eben schon getätigt hat.
Ja, nur nachdem die Kommission eine schlechte Netzzentralitätsposition hat und der Rat dann auch, hätten wir zwei zu eins.
Also hier ist auch wichtig sozusagen, wie viele Institutionen haben welche Meinung und ähm insofern wir wissen nicht, wie die neue Kommission dann wirklich ist. Die kann auch ihre Meinung ändern.
Es sind neue Handel der Personen und so, das ist noch ein großes Fragezeichen, aber.
Wir können uns auf jeden Fall nicht drauf ausruhen, dass dieser dieses eine Organ, das Parlament da uns alleine den Arsch retten wird.
Das heißt, man müsse im Prinzip jetzt auch erstmal wieder Druck auf die Kommission ausüben.
Ja, auch die Kommission ist ist natürlich klar in der Pflicht. Ähm da was jetzt so irgendwie schwierig man in den Herings wurde ja auch schon.
Nachgefragt von vielen Abgeordneten, wie ist das jetzt mit der Netzautralität? Da hat sich auch Günther Günther Oettinger sehr komisch geäußert, dass er für keine extreme Netzzentralität ist und dass in Stufen gelöst haben will
Ähm was eine sehr komische Aussage ist, weil entweder man hat eine Zentralität oder nicht und in Stufen geht das halt nicht, weil ja äh.
Neutralität extrem.
Ja, das ist auch äh dieses, diese diese Meer, die von den Telkus gestreut wird, das ist so etwas wie extreme Netzneutralität gäbe. Wir reden halt einfach davon, dass wir ein Grundprinzip des Netzes, wie's immer schon war, festschreiben wollen und denen
neue Geschäftsmodelle verbieten wollen, die sie in der Schublade haben und jetzt eh schon überall in Europa ähm etablieren, also weil,
Das ist ganz wichtig für diese Diskussion, wo wir heute stehen und das war auch die Quintessenz von meinem Talk. Ähm wir sehen immer mehr Verletzungen der Netzzentralität in ganz Europa.
Und ähm uns rennt langsam die Zeit davon. Ähm wenn das der, was der Rat nämlich gerne macht, ist zu verzögern
Ähm das ist so einer der liebsten Taktiken.
Der Rat sehr intransparent ist, nachdem's dort keine fixen Fristen gibt, in denen irgendetwas besprochen oder behandelt werden muss, können die sich eigentlich unendlich Zeit lassen. Die können auch äh drei Jahre.
Über irgendetwas und dann entscheiden, dass sie's ähm fallen lassen und gar nichts behandeln dazu
Und ähm ist ein sehr mächtiges Instrument im Rat, ist auch die Kontrolle über die Tagesordnung
Also ob man überhaupt noch ähm auf der Agenda stehen hat, dass man über ein gewisses Gesetzespaket spricht oder ob das äh erst gar nicht mehr behandelt wird.
Offiziell nicht drüber redet, dann können auch die Länder, die für starke Netzertralität sind, eigentlich nichts mehr tun.
Und da gab's auch eine komische Meldung von von Heiser, das ist das,
die EU-Verordnung zur Netzzentralität schon auf Eis liegt. Ähm das konnte ich nicht bestätigen. Da wird weiter drüber geredet. Ähm jetzt im Oktober nochmal und im November definitiv.
Und der Zeitplan, den ich für realistisch halte, ist, dass man sich jetzt entweder zweitausendvierzehn noch einig wird oder im ersten Quartal zweitausendfünfzehn.
Und äh wenn man bis dahin keine Einigung hat auf europäischer Ebene, dann muss man.
Die Netzzentralitätsverordnung eigentlich als gestorben Ansehen und sich um nationale Gesetze bemühen. Weil.
Auf europäischer Ebene, ähm wie gesagt, das Ganze kann man sehr schlank verschleppen.
Und es gibt aber sowieso zweitausendsechzehn die Reform des Telekom Rechtsrahmens. Daran erinnern sich vielleicht manche noch ähm zweitausendneun gab's diese große Reform des Telekom-Rechtsrahmens in der EU.
Und äh so eine Reform steht jetzt wieder an. Und wahrscheinlich wird dann einfach, wenn man sich bis Anfang zweitausendfünfzehn nicht geeinigt hat, dass alles verschoben auf zweitausendsechzehn.
Wenn das aber passiert, heißt das, dass wir frühestens zweitausendachtzehn einen effektiven Schutz der Netzzentralität haben werden auf europäischer Ebene.
Bis zweitausendachtzehn ist die ganze Sache gestorben, also bis zweitausendachtzehn hat äh jeder Provider Zero-Rating-Produkte auf dem Markt ähm
und, und, und. Hat angefangen damit Geld zu verdienen, dass er die Netzwerk verletzt. Und deswegen.
Ähm das ist so meine Message, müssen wir dann halt äh wirklich auf nationale Gesetze bauen.
Eine Frage, du meinst Änderungen des Rechtsrahmens, das habe ich nicht ganz verstanden. Welcher welcher Rechtsrahmen ändert sich da?
Äh das ist eine Summe von Gesetzespaketen, da geht's ähm hauptsächlich um ähm also eigentlich ausschließlich nur um Richtlinien.
Die äh reglementieren, wie du äh Telekommunikationsdienste innerhalb der EU anbieten kannst, ähm Universaldienstrichtlinie ist da ein wichtiger Punkt, ganz viel Konsumentenschutz, ähm so so eben auch Holze, Sachen, teils auch Roaming
ähm das ist ähm zweitausendneun ein großer Kampf gewesen, noch vor meiner Zeit. Äh hat da ganz viel gemacht
und ähm in der EU ist, ist das es halt einfach so, dass man in regelmäßigen Abständen.
Ähm dieses diesen Telekommunikationsbereich sich hernimmt und da einfach reformiert, ein Teil Update macht sozusagen.
Sowas steht äh wieder an. Zweitausendsechzehn und ähm deswegen sind jetzt auch einige Länder, vor allem eben, das sind.
Die dort sitzen, die kommen alle aus dem Ministerien, ist inzwischen die Meinung so, OK, dann lass uns das ganze Ding irgendwie äh nicht angreifen und wir nehmen uns das vor, wenn wir's in, in der großen Reform sowieso mit all diesen Themen uns auseinandersetzen müssen.
Okay, also wenn ich dich richtig äh verstehe, äh sagst du
wenn es jetzt nicht gelingt, im mit der Kommission, dem Rat, dem Parlament zusammen eben wirklich mal eine finale Verordnung zum Thema Netzneutralität zu verabschieden und das weiter verschleppt wird, dann wird es dazu führen, dass die ohnehin anstehenden
Updates zu
Telekommunikationsverordnung, die es bereits gibt, dazu führen, dass eben sich quasi Netzneutralitätsfeindliche Elemente in zunehmenden Maße verstetigen.
Genau.
Dann wirkt da, so wie du's grade gesagt hast, ähm die Netzneutalitätsfeindlichen Elemente sind halt einfach die Internetprovider in dem Fall, die über ihre Produkte halt Fakten schaffen, also gerade eben die Großen, die haben ein Interesse dadran.
Ähm dass es ähm mehr Netzotralitätsfeindliche Produkte gibt, in Österreich sind wir jetzt gerade in Deutschland, hattet ihr das ja sowieso in der Vergangenheit schon ganz stark.
Und ich würde auch meinen, dass ihr das jetzt in Teilen auch.
Dass diese Volumentarife, die jetzt eingeführt werden, die an sich keine Verletzung der Netzautralität sind, auch eine Vorstufe sind, weil man halt eben eine künstliche Verknappung herstellen muss, damit man danach die Ausnahme von dieser Verknapp.
Verkaufen kann. Und deswegen, wenn wir es auf E-Webe nicht zu einer Einigung schaffen, dann muss man national was tun.
Auch die deutsche Bundesregierung hat sich ja zuletzt darauf ausgeredet, dass man,
ähm den den Verordnungsvorschlag von Rösler deswegen nicht wieder aufgreift, äh weil ich ja auf EU-Ebene was gemacht wird
obwohl sie eigentlich im Koalitionsvertrag äh drinnen steht, dass man was über Netzatalität machen will, ist da ja bis jetzt auch in Deutschland nichts passiert.
Genau da müsste man dann wieder anknüpfen, äh eben im im Frühjahr zweitausendfünfzehn, wenn auf EU-Event nichts passiert.
Es sind ähm sind die Edri jetzt irgendwie besser aufgestellt als vorher. Personell und äh was so den allgemeinen Neumond betrifft.
Ähm.
Ja, so Dolmond ist bei immer gut, das ist ein Wahnsinn, wie wie hoch das Standing von der Organisation in Brüssel ist. Ähm und ja, es wurde auch aufgestockt. Ähm es sind jetzt fünf Mitarbeiter, ähm aktuell im Büro,
wenn ich mich nicht verzählt habe und ähm die haben jetzt auch ähm eben Leute, die sich mit den ganzen Dossiers beschäftigen und ähm die,
die sind da auch weiter dran. Also idri ist da auch äh neben Access Now eigentlich die Adresse für europäische Netzpolitik, äh wenn einer das interessiert, auf jeden Fall den Blog verfolgen
und auch sonst äh die unterstützen wo es geht.
Ja, nehmen wir auch noch mal äh rein. Das heißt, ich schließe dadraus, dass äh sich auch die Spendensituation etwas verbessert hat.
In die Finanzen habe ich jetzt gar keinen Einblick so genau, wie das bei bei Edri ausschaut, auf jeden Fall nicht gut. Es ist in äh der ganzen im ganzen Netzpolitikbereich leider sehr prekär
Ähm und ähm ja, also ich die haben halt auch äh so ein Gemisch an Finanzierung ähm
Teils aus äh Förderungen und Funding. Äh früher auch Funding von der Kommission, äh von der Open Society Foundation und von allen möglichen Fördergebern, ähm denen halt äh das Thema ein Anliegen ist
Aber genaue Sachen, ich weiß da jetzt nicht, wie es aktuell aussieht.
Gut, na dann verlinken wir einfach mal hier auf die äh Spendenseite von Etri kann nicht schaden. Gut, ähm.
Kommen wir zu deiner.
Aktuellen Tätigkeit, nachdem du also jetzt Brüssel wieder verlassen hast und nach Wiegen gegangen bist und dich zu Ende geurlaubt hast, zu einem gleichen neuen Posten angetreten, wenn ich das richtig sehe.
Ja ähm also ich beginne nicht da. Ähm ich glaube der AKV hat Österreich, der ist ja allen irgendwie ein Begriff, der hat ähm.
Nicht zu viel zu tun mit dem deutschen Ackervorrat, auch wenn natürlich Ziele und der Name gleich sind.
Aber äh nachdem der Ackervorrat in Österreich diese riesigen Erfolge eingesammelt hat mit der Abschaffung der Vorratsdatenspeicherung,
auf europäischer und auf nationaler Ebene und dann davor auch noch diese riesige Bürgerinitiative mit hunderttausend Unterschriften, war für die handelnden Akteure dort klar, okay, wenn wir jemals eine Chance haben in Österreich.
Professionelle Netzpolitikorganisation aufzubauen, die auch nicht nur aus Ehrenamtlichen besteht und und nur da irgendwie, wo gerade Leute Lust haben,
Politik macht, sondern die halt wirklich professionell arbeitet. Da muss das der Ackervorrat sein und dann muss man das jetzt probieren.
Ja und dann haben wir es probiert, da wurde ich eben jetzt sozusagen bestellt als die Person, die dort mal ähm.
Diese Professionalisierung verarmt vorantreiben soll und dazu hat man sich auch gleich ein äh neues Projekt herausgesucht, das ähm sozusagen der logische nächste Schritt ist für uns, nach diesen riesigen,
ähm Form von Verfassungs- und Europäischen Gerichtshof. Wir haben uns nämlich jetzt mal diese Urteile vorgenommen und wollen.
Diese Urteile gegen die Vorratsdatenspeicherung generalisieren als,
prinzipielle Handlungskataloge, wie denn zu einer Evaluierung von Überwachungsgesetzen zu erfolgen hat, wie man Antiterrorgesetze auf ihre Nützlichkeit, Notwendigkeit und Verhältnismäßigkeit, also ob sie verfassungskonform sind.
Überprüfen kann nach wissenschaftlichen Kriterien.
Und diesen Handlungskatalog, ähm den haben wir als äh Projekt eingereicht bei so einem Förderprogramm genannt Nettidee,
und ähm die da haben wir jetzt auch schon Rückmeldung bekommen. Wir werden ähm das Ding machen, wir haben aber leider nur die Hälfte der Fördersumme bekommen.
Was uns vor ein paar Probleme stellt, weil wir da jetzt äh so ein bissel unter unserem eigenen Anspruch nicht zurückschrecken wollen. Und äh für uns ist halt jetzt einfach wichtig, dass wir das Signal setzen,
es ist wichtig, dass weiter in Österreich was passiert, die die Urteile, die wir jetzt ähm
Fast geschenkt bekommen haben von den Höchstgerichten sind ein wahnsinnig großes Asset für die Netzpolitikbewegung, weil da einfach mal,
in Sachen Datenschutz und Massenüberwachung so wichtige Dinge drinnen stehen und die muss man jetzt halt wirklich an allen möglichen
Ecken und Enden anwenden und mit diesen Urteilen, die ja jetzt auch wirklich bindend sind in der ganzen EU, ähm muss man jetzt hergehen und mal den ganzen anderen Gesetzesbestand, der sich seit Nine Eleven angesammelt hat, aufarbeiten,
Ähm weil wir wir reden immer die ganze Zeit über diese NSE-Affäre und über den Bereich, der sich sowieso fast außerhalb jeder Rechtsstaatlichkeit,
befindet, aber wir müssen uns auch mal um den normalen sicherheitspolizeilichen Bereich kümmern und dort die ein bisschen Kahlschlag machen und die Kompetenzen wieder auf ein ähm demokratisch vertretbares Maß zurückstufen.
Und das ist, was wir uns da vorgenommen haben und dieser dieser Handlungskatalog ist so ein bisschen das Pflichtenheft für die Politik. Wir haben gesagt, wir können selber nicht evoluieren, weil wir sind ja eine NGO mit einer Meinung, aber wir wollen genau aufzeigen,
wie anhand dieser Urteile so einer Evaluierung zu passieren hat.
Also der Handlungskatalog für Politiker, die ihnen quasi in so einer Art Leitlinie gibt
was jetzt eigentlich geht oder nicht geht. So nach dem Motto, hier gucke mal
das war jetzt das Urteil in Österreich, das war das Urteil auf europäischer Ebene, das waren hier konkre
die vom Gericht geäußerten Begründungen und äh daraus abgeleiteten Entscheidungen
Das bedeutet, dass ihr äh ein Gesetz in der Form und in der Form machen könntet, aber in der Form geht's auf keinen Fall.
Deute ich das richtig, also das ist das, was ihr sozusagen wollt. So eine eine äh so eine
bleitung aus dem juristischen Text hin in so eine politische Handlungsvorgabe oder vor
was sie wie man das am besten ausdrückt. Aber halt so ein.
Was ist dann sozusagen anders als der Text? Also es ist erstmal nicht juristisch geschrieben, sondern es ist sozusagen in in klaren, kurzen äh Sätzen zusammengefasst oder wie.
Es soll möglichst verständlich sein, weil
das äh der Rezipient ist nicht nur die Politik, sondern auch ein bissel wirklich auch äh so äh der der Guide äh für Aktivisten zum Beispiel, wie man den am besten solche Überwachungsgesetze angreift. Ich gebe am besten ein Beispiel. Ähm also
Sind so ein tolles Ding. Wir haben ein Gesetz Bestimmungen, dass die
Polizei das Recht hat Handys zu orten im im Spezialfall und dann
Wird dafür halt ähm der im als Technik verwendet. IMSE-Catcher können jetzt aber um einiges mehr. Damit kann ich auch wirklich die Inhalte der Kommunikation
abfangen, ähm damit äh kann ich wirklich sozusagen konkret mir anschauen, wer es jetzt in dieser Funkzelle und das über einen längeren Bereich.
Kurze kurze Erläuterung für die, die nicht äh folgen können, also ein ist im Prinzip ein Gerät, was einem vorgegaukelt da wäre ein Mobilfunknetz, in das man sich dann einbucht, aber stattdessen bucht man sich in dieses Gerät ein und damit hört man so ein
Szenario, wo man quasi komplett abgelutscht werden kann, obwohl man eben glaubt, man würde ganz normal mit einem normalen Mobilfunknetz,
kommunizieren.
Genau, das ist, wir haben so irgendwie, wir wir listen mal alle Gesetze in Österreich, die wir uns anschauen wollen, die unserer Meinung nach potentiell gegen die Verfassung verstoßen
Dann schauen wir uns an, wie werden die genau implementiert? Was für Techniken setzt die Strafverfolgung ein, um dieses Gesetz auszunutzen,
und dann schauen wir uns die Technik an, was kann die, was ist so die Technikfolgenabschätzung von dem Zeug? Und dann erstellen wir die Kriterien, nachdem man, nach denen man das Ganze evolieren muss, also,
kann die Technik mehr als das Gesetz eigentlich erlaubt
Ähm wie schaut's mit dem Rechtsschutz aus? Wie wird äh Missbrauch verhindert oder geahndet? Ähm was gibt's für Transparenz oder für Informationsverpflichtungen von den Leuten, deren Daten da gerade abgeschnorchelt wurden? All diese Dinge, also,
Wir geben da wirklich sozusagen die wissenschaftliche Anleitung, wie man so eine Evaluierung machen sollte. Ähm gleichzeitig wird's aber auch ähm so ein kleiner Baukasten für Aktivisten, um sich jedes einzelne Gesetz anzuschauen, aha, was,
Was sind die Fragen, die ich stellen muss, um rauszufinden, ob das noch okay ist oder nicht.
Und damit er damit auch nicht nur für Aktivisten, sondern auch für Journalisten zum Beispiel. Mhm. Was heißt wissenschaftliche Ausarbeitung? Also welche Art Wissenschaftler sollen hier zum Einsatz kommen?
Ähm also wir haben beim Ackervorrat ein äh riesiges Team von äh Juristen. Das ist auch eigentlich so unsere größte Kompetenz und das ist die gute Art von Juristen, die alle sehr ähm verfassungsbeseelt und grundrechtsbesehlt sind.
Und dann haben wir äh weiter aus eben der Technikfolgenabschätzung, aus der Sozialwissenschaft, einige Techniker dabei und so aus diesem Sammelsurium
setzt sich das zusammen. Wirklich,
die Evaluierung würde wahrscheinlich eben von ähm einem entweder einer Anwaltskanzlei gemacht werden können, wenn's eine große ist oder äh von einer Universität. Wir sind aber dann meistens so eben im im Verfassungsrecht und in den juristischen Fakultäten.
Ja, wäre das nicht auch noch was für Politikwissenschaftler?
Hm. Hm. Ja, schöne Idee. Was äh, äh, wann, wann geht's los und was äh, glaubt ihr, was ihr da für eine Laufzeit haben werdet, bis da erste Ergebnisse kommen und in welcher Form sollen diese Ergebnisse, das Licht des Tages sehen?
Also ähm da sind wir jetzt noch ein bissel in Verhandlungen, weil wie gesagt, wir haben leider nur die Hälfte der Kohle bekommen und deswegen unser tolles Projekt, von dem wir eigentlich sehr überzeugt sind. Äh müssen wir jetzt schauen, wie wir das irgendwie mit der Hälfte der Mittel umsetzen können.
Wie groß sind die Mittel?
Ähm also wir haben da um fünfzigtausend Euro angesucht und wir haben jetzt fünfundzwanzigtausend bekommen.
Und er wiegt dir noch ein Crowdfunding zu machen für den Rest.
Das ist als Idee wird es grade diskutiert ähm und ist natürlich immer auch äh braucht Mut äh sich mit so einem großen an die Menschen zu richten, weil wenn der dann nicht zustande kommt, ist das natürlich auch ein Signal.
Deswegen sind wir noch ein bissel am am Überlegen wer das hört und irgendwie 'ne starke Meinung hat oder 'n paar Millionen auf dem Konto und findet, dass wir das auf jeden Fall machen sollten, kann sich ja bei uns melden
ähm aber an sich haben wir äh vor das so innerhalb eines Jahres zu machen. Das war der ursprüngliche Plan.
Und ähm wie gesagt, wir müssen aber jetzt so mit den, mit der neuen Situation, die sich erst vor vor einigen Tagen so ergeben hat, erstmal schauen, wie wir das dann einbau.
Ja, schöne Sache, also du bist ja jetzt äh offiziell Geschäftsführer beim AK Vorrat, bist du damit erstmal die einzige ähm hauptamtlich beschäftigte Person oder umfasst das noch weitere Menschen?
Hm, jetzt bin das nun mal nur ich vorläufig und eben halt auch mit ganz viel Hausmeisterthemen.
In Bezug auf äh neue Website Kommunikationskanäle professionalisieren und all das, was so an äh Netzpolitik, NGO, Business da ist, was eigentlich nicht viel mit Politik zu tun hat. Ähm aber das steht mir jetzt auch irgendwie so ins Haus.
Ähm und vorläufig bin das nur ich.
Ähm und nebenher mache ich aber weiter noch äh Netzentralität natürlich. Also weil da tut sich in Österreich auch grad ganz viel und das ist das ist dann wieder nur Hobby.
Aber Praktikanten dürfen sich bewerben.
Ja, wir freuen uns sehr über Praktikanten. Ähm wir haben schon ein paar, ähm eben auch ähm so so äh Juristen im Verden
Aber an sich, wer in Wien sitzt oder so im Umkreis von Wien und Netzpolitik begeistert ist, äh wir freuen uns immer über.
Interessierte, junge Leute, die was machen wollen. Äh sie können auch äh nicht jung sein und älter.
Gut, ihr wisst ja, in wen ihr euch äh zu wenden habt. Bleiben wir noch kurz in Österreich. Ähm
da gab's ja auch Neuigkeiten, äh Netzsperren seien ja zulässig, das hat der EuGH entschieden, da haben wir auch vor, glaube ich, vor vier Ausgaben hier schon mal drüber berichtet. In der Ausgabe hundertzehn.
Wo ähm,
auch ein wenig um Kino T O und diese ganze Geschichte ging, also die aus äh ich weiß gar nicht, wurden die auch aus Österreich heraus betrieben seiner Zeit oder waren die nur in Österreich so ein Thema?
Portale, die so Filme mit Online-Streaming angeboten haben.
Ähm.
Glaube, dass das war natürlich nie klar, weil hätte man gewusst, wo die genau sitzen, hätte man sie sofort verhaftet, aber ich glaube schon, dass die irgendwie so einen leichten, deutschen Konnex hatten. Ich weiß nicht, ob die Seite deutschsprachig war?
Aber in Österreich haben sie dann irgendwie halt eben das Verfahren eingeleitet. Ähm ich glaube daher kam einfach nur der Österreichbezug.
Und ja an sich äh äh du hast es gesagt, Kinotio war damals so der Aufhänger. Ähm die gibt's ja inzwischen nicht mehr. Ähm und da
ist aber jetzt trotzdem eben sozusagen die juristische mit dem wir leben müssen, weil der EuGH ist entschieden hat, dass äh Netzsperren aufgrund von Urheberrechtsverletzungen an sich schon okay sind und da,
ein sehr komisches Urteil ähm geliefert hat, wo
Teile von Dingen, gehen Teile nicht und äh an sich haben wir jetzt die Situation eben in Österreich, dass seit ähm dritten Oktober, glaube ich, ähm wir Internetsperren haben,
Also dass jetzt ähm Kino X T O und movie for K äh in den Netzen von mehreren großen Providern nicht mehr erreichbar sind.
Ähm und die Ist-Situation ist halt so, dass bei vor allem diesen Seiten, die wirklich Urheber, die wirklich vor ähm.
Übermäßig viele Urberichtsverletzungen ähm haben, dass die gespeichert gesperrt werden können,
über den simplen Brief, den äh eine Anwaltskanzlei, die einen äh Rechteinhaber vertritt, eben an die Internetprovider verschickt. Ähm,
ein lustiger hat das nicht funktioniert, da bleibt's auch spannend, ob äh eben so Seiten, die auch legale Inhalte anbieten, dann auch gesperrt werden könnten, also wo man da sozusagen die Grenze zieht.
Was heißt das hat nicht funktioniert?
Ja, da haben hat das Gericht entschieden, nee, also da gibt's ja auch legale Inhalte, auf äh und deswegen ähm dürft ihr die nicht sperren.
Und ähm ich weiß nicht, ob man dann irgendwie auf äh diesen ähm Kino XTO und ähnlichen Plattformen dann bald äh Creative Commons Filme sehen wird, damit die sich auch dieser Rechtslücke bedienen.
Ja, wollte ich auch gerade sagen.
Ey.
Auch nicht die schlechteste die schlechteste Folge davon, ne. Aber betrifft das wieder nur große Ice-Peace oder generell alle?
Sie haben sich jetzt mal zuerst auf die Großen konzentriert, aber das soll natürlich sukzessiver auch auf die kleinen ausgeweitet werden. Die Großen haben's jetzt auch immer auf ein äh Gerichtsverfahren ankommen lassen
ähm und äh an sich bräuchte es das aber gar nicht, also es gibt da keinen Richtervorbehalt
was ähm wirklich äh horrend äh äh grundrechtswidrig ist eigentlich, weil dann eben wirklich an einer
äh ein Rechteinhaber über einen Anwalt, eine Informationssperre, eine Netzsperre erwirken kann. Das dürfte eigentlich nicht sein. Die Großen haben's jetzt halt immer auf dem Gerichtsverfahren ankommen lassen, indem sie sich geweigert haben
aber bei den kleinen Eisbies, die ja oft wirklich nur zwei, drei Mann Unternehmen sind, ist zu befürchten, dass die einfach sofort sperren werden, weil sie,
die Kosten für ein Gerichtsverfahren sich nicht leisten können, auf dem bleiben sie nämlich auch sitzen
und ähm da ist sicherlich mit ähm einer denkbar schlechten Situation zu rechnen, weil damit gibt's auch keine Transparenz dadrüber, was jetzt gerade bei wem gesperrt ist.
Ähm und im Moment reden wir da nur von DNS, Sperren, theoretisch wären aber auch IP-Sperren denkbar, ähm wird auch schon gefordert von den Rechteinhabern,
Ähm wirklich äh schlimm wird's dann, wenn man das Urteil genau liest und und äh feststellt, dass da auch theoretisch VPN-Betreiber davon betroffen sind.
Mhm. Generell sozusagen, dass sie generell rausgehalten werden. Oje. Na ja, viel Spaß.
Ja nicht, dass VPNs generell gesperrt werden beim ISB, aber das VPNs auf einmal auch Dinge filtern müssen und Sperren etablieren müssen.
Ach so, verstehe. Das VPN, wie äh als Peace behandelt werden. Das heißt, es gibt jetzt auch überhaupt gar keine Klassifikation zwischen großer Provider, kleiner Provider, wie das in Deutschland äh ist, dass man nur sozusagen erst ab einer bestimmten Größe überhaupt für solche Maßnahmen herangezogen werden kann.
Also es gibt schon so einen gewissen.
Ähm es gibt schon ein bisschen was in die Richtung. Das ist halt vertretbarer Aufwand sein muss, aber wie das dann genau ausgelegt wird, ist fragwürdig. Also vor allem so in einem DNS-Server, Records äh,
ist vielleicht ein vertretbarer Aufwand, ist es vielleicht nicht, weiß ich nicht. Ähm andere signifikant, also ein richtiger Schutz ist das auf jeden Fall noch nicht.
Ist ja jetzt auch schon drüber nachgedacht worden, so Communitys wie Freifunk oder so was, äh da auch mit einzubeziehen.
Na, ist meines Wissens nach zur Zeit noch kein Thema, so dieses
Ganze Topic Störerhaftung äh ist in Österreich, glaube ich, auch noch nicht zu angekommen, zumindest ich habe mich damit noch nicht beschäftigt und das noch nicht so wahrgenommen.
Aber ja, natürlich sind die dann auch davon betroffen, weil wir haben auch eine riesige Freifunnkemeinde mit Funkfeuer äh und die ähm haben auch ordentliches Internet und darüber, die kann man auch als ISB-Ersatz verwenden sozusagen.
Und natürlich könnten die dann theoretisch auch davon betroffen sein.
Ja. Und äh wenn du meinst, es gibt kein Richter vorbehalt. Wer entscheidet denn jetzt überhaupt, wer welche.
Welche Zeit in diese Liste aufgenommen werden müssen,
und wer hält diese zentrale Sammlung vor, also wer pflegt quasi diese offizielle äh Liste und wer entscheidet, welcher ISP
dass jetzt umzusetzen hat, weil wenn's derzeit nur die größten fünf sind, muss ja irgendeine Identität geben, die das jetzt
entschieden hat, liegt es beim Ministerium, liegt das bei der Polizei.
Nee. Ähm also es gibt den äh sehr äh lästigen Verein für Antipiraterie. VAP
ähm auch liebevoll genannt Wabler. Äh das sind ähm die ja die die Urheberrechts,
äh in Österreich, man kann sie ruhig Content Mafia nennen. Äh und diejenigen sind es, die solche Sperrlisten intern führen, die sind sozusagen die
Akteure der Rechteinhaber in Österreich ähm und die stellen sich dann eben auch in die Medien und fordern äh solche Netzsperren.
Ähm und die sind äh zwar nicht rechtlich, diejenigen, die die Prozesse anstreben, aber äh es ist sehr stark zu vermuten, dass die das ganze orchestrieren.
Und ähm was dann wirklich konkret wo gespeichert wird, hängt halt eben von diesen Sperrverfügungen ab.
Aber wenn man dieses Büro ist doch eine rein private Initiative jetzt, das ist ja nichts des Staates.
Ja, das ist ein Verein, ähm der so ein bisschen an der Wirtschaftskammer angedockt ist und der Verein hat dann eben.
Wie soll man das sagen? Der Verein äh äh ist natürlich rechtlich nicht derjenige, der auftritt und der diese Briefe verschickt. Ähm das sind die Rechteinhaber wie Konstantin Film, die sich dann irgendein lokales Anwaltsbüro nehmen und mit
ihrem Rechtstitel als rechte Inhaber dann diese Briefe an die ISBs verschicken.
Ähm aber wie gesagt, da gibt's jetzt nichts, was über ein Ministerium läuft mit zentraler Sperrliste.
Und es gibt da jetzt auch nicht per die voll zu eine Gerichtsprozess wo wo von neutraler Stelle darüber entschieden wird ob diese Sperrverfügung jetzt OK ist oder nicht.
Das heißt jetzt, das darf also im Prinzip jeder jetzt irgendwelche Sperren von irgendwelchen, bei irgendwelchen ISPs einklagen.
Theoretisch ja.
Das ist doch das ist doch das ist doch, das ist doch so toller Unfug. Also das äh erzählst du mir jetzt im Ernst, das ist jetzt die Realität in Österreich. Ich falle komplett ins Essen.
Naja, das Ganze ist halt dadurch zustande gekommen, dass der EuGH entschieden hat und eigentlich war das so ein ziemlich großes Alarmsignal an die Politik. Nur die Politik hat sich die Ohren zugehalten.
Und äh politisch haben sich auch alle Parteien äh schon dazu geäußert, dass das Jahr untragbar ist, wie das jetzt gerade gelöst wird und dass man da auf jeden Fall irgendwas machen muss,
nur sie machen halt alle nichts, weil sie genau wissen, dass sie jetzt ohne, dass sie
einen kleinen Finger rühren, eine Seite des ganzen Urheberrechts des Kurses glücklich machen können. Ähm weil sie müssen keine Gesetzesänderung machen, sie müssen keine politische Verantwortung übernehmen,
die Gerichte haben das so entschieden.
Und äh anstelle da irgendwie als Gesetzgeber reinzugehen und ordentliche Regeln zu machen, die auch den Rechtsstaat garantieren, tut die Politik halt bis jetzt noch nichts.
Spannend wird, dass wir halt auch bald eine Urheberrechtsnovelle haben, die in Österreich kommen sollte, also wir müssen eine EU-Richtlinie umsetzen, eigentlich noch bis Ende Oktober zweitausendvierzehn.
Und da wir so zumindest meine Hoffnung, dass man auch äh irgendetwas reinschreibt zu dem Bereich, aber realistisch ist es nicht. Ich befürchte wirklich, dass sie,
die Politik an der Stelle ähm sich zwar öffentlich drüber echauffiert, aber nicht wirklich viel tut.
Aber wenn jetzt Eispiece sich jetzt schon dagegen gewehrt haben.
Und das Ganze so auf fuckligen Füßen steht, das ist eigentlich gar keine wirkliche gesetzliche Ordnung dafür gibt, sondern man sich ausschließlich jetzt auf diese, also gibt's überhaupt ein ein Gesetz, ein österreichisches Gesetz
in irgendeiner Form regelt.
Äh gibt es nicht, hat es auch nie gegeben, aber ähm eben weil.
Dieser Streit ähm von inner in den österreichischen Gerichten zwischen einem ISB und einem Rechteinhaber bis vor den EuGH eskaliert ist.
Ähm hat der EuGH dazu entschieden und ähm Orge Hallenscheider sind direkt anwendbar in allen achtundzwanzig Mitgliedsländern, ähm wenn der OGH, also,
das ist ja dann so, dass man dann, wenn man vom EuGH ein Urteil bekommt, die nationalen Gerichte auch nochmal tätig werden. Die haben ja vorher gefragt, äh wie ist denn das jetzt genau? Äh lieber EuGH, wenn der ihnen eine Antwort gibt
dann übernehmen sie diese Antwort auch gleich in nationales Recht und äh beenden das Verfahren. Und deswegen hat Österreich jetzt sofort diese Konsequenz bekommen.
Ähm aber da wurde nie national ein Gesetz gemacht, sondern das ist wirklich allein äh aufgrund der der Grundrechtsabwägungen des EUGH und aufgrund der.
Gerichtsverfahren national so gekommen, wie es jetzt heute hier liegt.
Super.
Das ist auch der Kernpunkt von meinem Artikel bei bei Netzpolitik Punkt org. Das ist halt hier wirklich
Das ist die große Gefahr, ja. Wir haben jetzt dieses, dieses Verrückte Instrument, dass wir eben den EuGH um Antwort bitten und dann kann er
entscheiden äh ähm wie das ist und das hat auch wirklich das letzte Wort. Und äh über dieselbe Art von Verfahren könnte man jetzt eigentlich in den meisten Ländern hergehen und die Vorratsdatenspeicherung abschaffen und Netzsperren einführen.
Hm.
Sehr komischer Äuger.
Na, dann schauen wir doch noch mal ganz kurz äh ein wenig nach Deutschland. Da ist man ja mit den Gesetzen dann äh immer ein bisschen schneller und Österreich guckt sich auch immer gerne so viel ab in Deutschland,
Wir haben ja hier ein äh totales Erfolgsmodell gebaut. Ja, die Rede ist natürlich vom äh Leistungsschutzrecht äh
Der VG Media, wir hatten das ja neulich, ähm wie dieser ganze Wahnsinn rund um dieses Leistungsschutzrecht sich weiter äh entwickelt
teilweise mit so etwas weinerlichen Äußerungen schon
der VG Media, ja, die jetzt sozusagen Google dazu zwingen möchte, gerne doch ihre Angebote anzunehmen, die Google aber gar nicht will, weil das kostet ja Geld und das irgendwie alles vollkommen äh absurd. Im Prinzip passiert
genau das, was äh alle Kritiker dieses Gesetzes vorhaben, auch schon vorher gesagt haben.
Es ist jetzt eine etwas merkwürdige Situation entstanden. Ich blicke auch selber schon gar nicht mehr so richtig durch. Es gibt da äh die unterschiedlichsten Meldungen, interessanterweise hat der Standard ähm.
Äh da auch schon äh darüber berichtet, also man merkt, die Diskussion wird in äh Österreich auf jeden Fall auch verfolgt.
Ähm genau, ähm ja, also man ist jetzt der Meinung, dass äh ja googelt
gegen das Kartellrecht äh verstoßen würde. Wir wissen ja, dass deutsche Kartellamt es da irgendwie ganz anderer Meinung, ja
weil die sich ja schon neulich dazu geäußert haben, nachdem VW Media schon versucht hat, da Klage zu erheben, hat das Kartellamt einfach gesagt, so, naja, wir wissen überhaupt nicht, wovon ihr redet und äh nimmt das mal bitte mal wieder zurück. Wir werden da noch nicht mal drüber entscheiden
was ja im Prinzip schon mal so eine große Ohrfeige gewesen ist. Jetzt äh hat man irgendwie versucht so auch über Medienberichte und Interviews und so weiter. Irgendwie diesen Eindruck zu erzeugen. Google wäre jetzt hier irgendwie in der Bringschuld. Aber Google hat halt einfach jetzt beschlossen, na ja,
also wenn ihr wollt, dass wir dafür Geld bezahlen, dann lassen wir das mal raus. Hat auch angekündigt, dass ihr an Anfang Oktober, Anfang
Die ganzen in der VG Media organisierten Verlage aus ihrem News-Angebotsdienst,
nicht herauszunehmen, aber zumindest äh wie das ja auch vom Gesetz her gefordert wird. Die Zitate äh rauszunehmen, Bilder rauszunehmen und nur noch.
Ähm Titel zu verwenden. Ich bin etwas verwirrt in der Hinsicht, weil.
Ich schon auch, schaue jetzt auch grad noch mal. Jetzt finde ich natürlich grade mal wieder nix, aber eine eine Weile lang gab's auch durchaus noch Artikel von.
Welt DE et cetera, die dort äh genommen werden oder Bilder, ähm aber so oder so, das Kriegsball ist da äh kräftig.
Graben worden und jetzt gibt es auf jeden Fall auch Berichte ähm.
Dass ähm ja, wenn halt das Kartellamt der Meinung ist, das ginge so nicht und man könne dagegen nicht klagen, ja dann müsste man ja wahrscheinlich mal das Kartellrecht ändern.
Äh nebst dem Hinweis, dass die Bundesregierung das ja irgendwie auch findet,
Ja? Da gibt's jetzt irgendwie noch nix konkretes. Ist mir jetzt auch gerade selber noch so ein bisschen unklar. Also äh Sigma Gabriel
fordere er zwar keine Zerschlagung von Google, ja, aber eine,
eine Erweiterung des Kartellrechts könne er sich äh schon irgendwie vorstellen, beziehungsweise darüber würde geredet werden.
Ja, das ist äh natürlich, also,
viel Konkreteres habe ich dazu jetzt noch nicht gefunden, finde ich aber schon mal eine recht beeindruckende Diskussion. Ähm so nach dem Motto, was nicht passt, wird passend gemacht. Erst macht man mal ein Gesetz, was so ein bisschen der Realität widerspricht. Äh dann stellt man fest,
dass er sich irgendwie nicht durchsetzen lässt,
und dann ähm geht man her und sagt, naja okay, dann müssen wir halt jetzt wohl alle anderen Gesetze, die dem irgendwie widersprechen oder die irgendwie verhindern, dass wir dieses bekloppte Gesetz in irgendeiner Form
anwendbar machen können, müssen wir dann halt irgendwie auch noch ändern. Also das wird sicherlich noch sehr spannend. Ich erwarte da auch ehrlich gesagt ähm
Ja, in meiner optimistischen Weltsicht erwarte ich da so nicht unbedingt, dass das Ganze,
äh Erfolg haben wird, wird aber trotzdem interessant sein, das zu verfolgen. Äh auf der anderen Seite gibt's aber auch Berichte, wie zum Beispiel bei Zeit Online.
Auch schon so die Einschätzung, dass man bei der VG Media äh eher eine Kapitulation der Verlage vor Google erwartet
Was ich persönlich auch eher erwarten würde, dass also einfach, dass ähm
Ziel der VG Media hier an der Stelle äh ausreichend Eindruck bei Google zu schinden. Das ist einfach nicht
erfolgt ist und nichts desto stattdessen sogar
sich genau in die andere Richtung verkehrt, das nehme ich jetzt im Prinzip all die da bei Media dabei sind, bestraft werden und nicht von dieser Strafe jetzt betroffen sein wollen und dementsprechend dann auch ihre Unterstützung für VG Media zurückziehen,
werden. Was jetzt auch noch nicht passiert ist.
Also ich habe immer gefunden, ähm dass äh von dir angekündigte Reduzieren der Google Newsergebnisse auf den Titel hat Google verschoben vom neunten auf den dreiundzwanzigsten Oktober auf bitte der Verlage.
Übermorgen, okay, alles klar.
Ja ähm und ich finde das an sich schon spannend, also da da hat man sich ein Gesetz gewunschen, das hat man bekommen und dann, oh Wunder tut das Gesetz, äh das, was es tun soll, aber äh eben das, was drin steht und nicht das Erwartete,
Und äh jetzt ist halt die Frage, wie verhält sich die Politik? Also ähm dass ich äh da Teile der Regierung auf einmal so vor die Verlage stellen. Das ist, glaube ich, zu erwarten.
Die Frage ist, ob sie halt auch wirklich danach Schritte setzen werden, also ob sie da jetzt gegen das Kartellamt vorgehen und ähm also das Kartellrecht erweitern ist ja auch nur neusprech für das Kartellrecht ändern.
Und ähm
andererseits auch wieder spannend, das jetzt so irgendwie die Unterscheidung gemacht wird zwischen äh VG Media und den eigentlichen Verlagen. Also hier wird vielleicht schon versucht, die Verwertungsgesellschaft so aus dem.
Bösen dastehen zu lassen, der nach vorne prescht, wer wohingegen die Verlage sich jetzt mal eher zurückhalten äh und vielleicht nicht auf das Sinken der Schiff setzen wollen,
Ähm.
Ganz spannend finde ich's noch, dass überhaupt Spiegel Online ja überhaupt nicht äh dabei ist bei diesem Pool. Äh die sind doch auch äh irgendwie so Springerspeerspitze, dachte ich immer, oder?
Nein, Spiegel ist ja nicht Springer, nein, nein. Die die Welt
ähm Bild vor allem äh Welt, Welt am Sonntag, äh nein, ein Spiegel ist äh der eigene äh Spiegelverlag,
damit eigentlich nichts zu tun, Zeit hält sich da auch raus und so. Es ist im Wesentlichen nur wirklich so äh Springer und noch ein paar andere. Ich kann nochmal kurz gucken, wer da alles äh organisiert ist. Wir hatten das hier irgendwann auch schon mal aufgelistet, aber ich hab's natürlich schon wieder vergessen.
Bevor ich was Falsches sage, fünfundzwanzig Medienunternehmen, da finden sich hier.
Antenne, Axel Springer, Hubert Burda, Media, also Burda Gruppe, DuMont,
Münchner Zeitungsverlag, ProSieben, Sat.1, media, viele Radiosender im Übrigen.
Aber und äh Verlagsgesellschaft aus Hannover, aber dann.
Aber die anderen sind halt nicht dabei und ich glaube, bei der Zeit und beim Spiegel, da betrachtet man das auch so ein bisschen zu viel Sand aus der Ferne und denkt sich so, lass die mal
sich die einrennen, weil die das einfach in der Form so nie gefordert haben. Ich meine, das Ganze ist ja nun wirklich auch ein Gesetz von Springers Gnaden, das Ganze ist ja
direkt von einem Springer Mitarbeiter da auch verhandelt worden. Auf der Gegenseite saß er auch ein Exspringer Mitarbeiter äh für die Regierung am Tisch. Also das war schon alles sehr fissy. Und ehrlich gesagt, wenn ich jetzt so Zitate höre von
Sigmar Gabriel oder meinetwegen auch anderen Vertretern, die sich da noch zu äußern mögen, äh so in Richtung mit, na ja, da müsste man ja mal drüber diskutieren, ob man da nicht was mit dem Kartellrecht macht, dann klingt das für mich auch so ein bisschen nach diesem
Zumindest nach so einer Simulation eines eines ähm wie soll ich sagen, eines Mitspielens bei dem Spiel, weil,
es macht ja immer noch den Eindruck. Ehrlich gesagt, ich sehe auch keinen Indiz. Kein anderes Indiz.
Warum die Politik dem überhaupt nachgegeben hat. Weil also jeder, der sich das irgendwie in Ruhe anschaut, weiß, das kann irgendwie alles nicht funktionieren. Trotzdem hat man das irgendwie gemacht. Warum macht man das? Man hat das gemacht, weil hier einfach.
Springer und mit Springer natürlich vor allem eben diese
Medien macht der Boulevard Zeitung und des konservativen Trends
gesagt haben, wir wollen das gerne haben und wenn wir nicht kriegen, was wir wollen, dann schreiben wir euch in Grund und Boden. Und das ist natürlich einfach eine Grundangst, die in der deutschen Politik, wie auch,
anderen Ländern auf eine andere Form auch existiert. Und Springer,
hat halt einfach immer noch eine ganze Menge Gewicht. So, deswegen wird da geredet und gemacht und am Ende wird abgewogen und dann haben sie sich wahrscheinlich einfach gedacht, na ja
scheiß auf dieses Leistungsschutzrecht, die paar Pfennige, da interessiert keinen Menschen. Wir machen das jetzt einfach mal, dafür haben wir woanders dann irgendwie unseren Freigang. Dass das natürlich gerade
ähm so eine
schwierige Debatte auslöst, im Netz und das ist natürlich auch ein unheimliches Bedrohungspotential hat für eine potenzielle Startupindustrie, die sie auch immer ganz gerne feiern
Das halt einfach etwas, was einfach grundlegend nicht verstanden wird,
Solche Argumente würden zwar geäußert, aber das ist, glaube ich, auch einfach in dieser aktuellen Politikergeneration einfach noch nicht,
drin, dieses Verständnis, dass dass nicht nur das LSR, aber vor allem auch das LSR in seiner ganzen,
Annahme seinem ganzen Positionierung einfach Gift ist für eine aufstrebende Internetwirtschaft. Aber das das wird einfach nicht so empfunden, sondern man leitet sich einfach lässt sich immer noch leiten von den alten,
Wirtschaftsmotiven.
Ja, das ist halt auch nur zu befürchten, der Grund, aus dem sie es ursprünglich eingeführt haben, der ist halt immer noch da. Also die die Macht der Verlage auf die Politik, daran hat sich ja nichts geändert.
Ähm die Frage ist halt, äh welche Längen sie da nehmen werden, also da wirklich ins Kartellrecht einzugreifen.
Das das hat ja dann potentiell auch noch ganz andere Kollateralschäden, die nicht abzuschätzen sind, also.
Also ich glaube am Ende wird das einfach gegen gegen die, gegen die Wand fahren. Was ist denn eigentlich mit Österreich? Die finden auch immer alles so toll, was wir in Deutschland machen.
Ja, ja, leider, also, Leistungsschutzrecht ist in Österreich ähm vom Fett, vom Verband österreichischer Zeitungsverleger, auch aufgegriffen worden und die trommeln auch schon jetzt seit äh
einigen Monaten dafür so ein Leistungsschutzrecht. Auch in Österreich einzuführen. Ähm da hat man dann auch lustig sehen können, als da in Deutschland sich die,
Zahl der Momente gehäuft hat und immer klarer wurde, dass dieses Gesetz auch nachdem es durchgekommen ist, nicht das tut, was es tun sollte, hat man dann ähm die Korrektur angepasst, ja aber wir wollen's ja ganz anders machen als die Deutschen
Äh wenn man dann nachfragt beim Fetts, wie genau, kriegt man keine Antwort
Ähm also auch sehr spiegelgleich äh die Details wurden sehr lange unter Verschluss gehalten. Ähm und bis heute haben wir eigentlich noch immer keinen Entwurf, wie so ein Leistungsschutzrecht in Österreich ausschauen sollte
aber die schon angesprochene
ähm Urheberrechtsnovelle, die eigentlich jetzt dann bald mal kommen müsste, äh hat mehrere solcher Bausteine und Leistungsschutzrecht ist eins davon, also ein anderes Festplattenabgabe, da wurde auch lange gestritten
und ähm da gab's auch eine sehr heftige Diskussion übers Urheberrecht. Äh gab's auch lange nicht mehr in Österreich, dass man dem so.
Dass da verschiedene Gesellschaftsgruppen sich so offen im Streit drüber geäußert haben, das fand ich eigentlich auch gut,
ähm an sich. Ähm es gibt noch ein paar unrealistische Sachen wie und äh ein ein Urhebervertragsrecht, also das wäre so Verbesserungen eigentlich für die Urheber,
auch so, weil die gegenüber den Verlagen äh eine Erleichterung bringen oder so im im Film Urheberrecht eben dafür, dass das ein bisschen realitätsnah wird. Ähm und.
Ähm was natürlich unser größtes Damoklesschwert ist, ist immer die IP-Auskunft, also dass die die
äh wollten ja schon mal auf Vorratsdaten zugreifen in Österreich ähm und vielleicht kriegen sie auch das.
Also und da und da gibt's mehrere Punkte, die drinnen sind. Ein Punkt, der wahrscheinlich sehr wahrscheinlich sein wird, dass er kommt, ist eine Preisbindung für E-Books.
Ähm und zwar gegenüber dem Endkunden, also dass Amazon E-Books ähm für den Kindle äh nur zu einem fixen Preis ausgeben kann.
Das ist natürlich äh ist ein ist ein heißes Thema ähm sehe ich auch schwarz und weiß, aber für den als Konsumentenschutzperspektive ist da so eine Preisbindung für E-Books natürlich äh.
Definitiv eine Verschlechterung, weil bei einem E-Book habe ich ja als äh als Kunde.
Als Nutzer viel weniger Rechte, das gehört mir ja nicht. Ich habe meine Nutzungslizenz, ich kann das nicht äh verkaufen, verschenken, verleihen
und wir haben auch bei bei Amazon schon gesehen, dass die dann teilweise solche Nutzungslizenzen für gekaufte Bücher ähm wieder zurückziehen im Nachhinein. Da gab's ja diesen diesen tollen Fall äh mit ähm
Buch, das im Nachhinein an auf den Geräten gelöscht wurde. Also,
Ja, Urheberrecht, große Baustelle, um in Österreich. Wir ist es leider immer noch nicht ganz vom Tisch. Also ich würde mir wünschen, dass da in Deutschland irgendwie.
Ähm der der Kollateralschaden gesehen wird und und man das zurücknimmt.
Wenn's schon nichts das tut, was man will, dass man's dann einfach komplett abschafft,
weil es hat ja auch andere Länder haben ja auch schon Leistungsschutzrecht Belgien zum Beispiel und das ist schon wirklich.
Modell, äh wenn man dem nicht entgegenwirkt, dann dann kommt das immer wieder, egal äh wie sehr wir uns einig sind, dass es eine schlechte Idee ist, ähm die Verlage reden miteinander und äh die kopieren halt sehr stark.
Dieser politischen Diskurse.
Das Problem ist natürlich, dass jetzt hier die Politik nicht ohne Not äh gleich wieder ein Rückzieher machen wird, um da einfach auch das Gesicht nicht zu verlieren, ne, weil man jetzt irgendwie zugibt, so ja
das war jetzt alles mal ein blödes Gesetz und so, das fällt ja auch dann auch gleich wieder auf sie zurück. Von daher glaube ich, äh geht gerade die Politik eher so ein bisschen in Duckstellung
gibt so ein bisschen so Signale mit na ja wir können ja da vielleicht das auch irgendwie nochmal flankieren und wenn da was nicht passt und so ja aber im Wesentlichen glaube ich ist der schwarze Peter dann doch jetzt eher
in der Lobby-Abteilung und muss ich da selber was einfallen lassen und ob ihnen das jetzt äh gelingt in Deutschland, ich habe da meine Zweifel.
Gut, kommen wir vielleicht zum Schluss noch mal zu ein paar schönen äh Sachen.
Und zwar wird äh viel gehackt ähm nicht nur in Deutschland, sondern eben auch in,
Österreich, äh ich weiß gar nicht, ob wir das hier bei Logbuch Netzpolitik schon
thematisiert haben. Ich befürchte fast gar nicht, ähm was auch ein bisschen daran lag, dass ich auf der Veranstaltung leider nicht war. Jugendtag gab's nämlich hier vor ein paar Wochen in Berlin. Ich glaube, ich hatte in der Friedshow ein bisschen was dazu äh erzählt und äh berichten lassen.
Aber es gab ja auch eine ähnliche Veranstaltung in Österreich.
Genau. Ähm also jetzt am Ende nochmal ein Wohlfühlthema. Äh Jugend hakt äh gab's, glaube ich, vor ein paar Wochen in Deutschland und eben auch vor einer Woche in Österreich. Ähm,
Unter dem Namen Jan Kodos Festival, wir mussten's irgendwie anders nennen, aber.
Das Konzept war genau dasselbe, nämlich, dass man ähm mit einer Gruppe von Jugendlichen sich ein Wochenende an irgendeinem Ort einsperrt und.
Die halt irgendwie so mit leichter Anleitung programmieren lässt so ein bissel mit Blick auf offene Daten, aber nicht nur,
und einfach mal so ähm
Jugendliche äh und und Computer sind ja an sich ein Erfolgsrezept und vor allem, wenn das so programmierbegeisterte Jugendliche sind, die dann in einem Umfeld äh sich bewegen, wo
sie gleichgesinnte treffen, äh dann wird das Magic und dann passieren da wirklich tolle Sachen. Also wir haben das in Österreich jetzt zum ersten Mal gemacht
Und äh ich war das selber auch vor Ort alle Tage und ich bin wirklich nachhaltig begeistert davon.
Ähm wie äh wie schnell und wie cool diese Projekte da entstanden sind.
Wie gut, dass du auch sozial funktioniert hat weil das eben halt doch dann eher so die Nerds sind, die jetzt vielleicht in normalen Gruppensituationen äh nicht so zu den am besten integriertesten gehören,
Ähm und das war, glaube ich, für alle Beteiligten äh ein Riesenerfolg
ähm und wir wir konnten da eben ähm am Wochenende in noch dazu im Schloss Laudern, also wir hatten ein echtes Schloss äh vor vor Wien, äh das uns dankbar irgendwie, dass das Bundeskanzleramt zur Verfügung gestellt hat, äh.
Wie heißt das Schloss?
Äh Schloss Laudern.
Laudon.
Ja, Schloss Laudern auf jeden Fall Bilder anschauen. Äh wir haben auch ein Flickeralbum.
Das verlinke ich dann noch. Das sind wirklich auch wahnsinnig tolle Bilder, die auch eigentlich recht gut transportieren wie das war. Also du hast da irgendwie so fünfzig Jugendliche äh mit acht Mentoren und noch äh ein bissel so und das in
ähm einem einem fressen Saal, der unter UNESCO Weltkulturerbe steht mit äh zig Bildern an der Wand, die alle schon ähm Jahrhunderte alt sind, das Schloss ist ursprünglich aus dem zwölften Jahrhundert
äh und äh wurde im achtzehnten restauriert und ähm das war halt fast ein ein ähm.
Äh unrealistischer Rahmen irgendwie, in dem das Ganze stattgefunden hat, aber wir haben's halt geschafft, dort ähm auch wirklich acht Projekte fertigzustellen.
Teils von Gruppen, die vorher fast noch nie programmiert hatten und da kamen sogar auch wirklich äh,
Tolle Anwendungen heraus, kann man sich auch anschauen in den Verlinkungen
äh ebenso äh teils äh so Vergleichsplattformen. Ich will irgendwie aus meinem Kaff wegziehen, also aus meinem kleinen Ort äh und dann vergleiche ich mal irgendwie so zwei Orte miteinander. Wie ist dort so.
Ähm die Arbeitslosenquote ähm was waren die letzten Wahlergebnisse dort und noch ein paar Sachen. So Locationbase, Spiele, wo ich äh mit einem einem Pinguin hinterherlaufen kann und Nachrichten hinterlassen kann auf einer Open Street.
So ein Spiel, wo man äh Bäume errät, also ich stehe vor einem Baum äh und dann äh muss ich raten, was für ein Baum das ist.
Baumbestimmung.
Genau, Trigetsa äh und äh halt wirklich so acht ganz coole ähm Anwendungen. Ähm paar davon Spiele, ein paar wirklich so,
ähm super Open Data Anwendungen. Äh das ist für uns vor allem das äh das
da war ich als Open Knowledge Foundation, die haben das veranstaltet äh und die die Geschichte bei so einem Jankos Festival oder Jugend hakt, ist halt immer auch, dass man dann vor den Politikern so wunderbar angeben kann. Schaut mal, das schaffen Jugendliche innerhalb von,
einem Wochenende. Äh und jetzt sag mir nochmal, wieso ihr diese Daten nicht rausgeben wollt. Und übrigens, wir haben sie auch gefragt, welche Daten sie am spannendsten,
finden würden und was sie am meisten interessiert und da haben wir, wir haben solche Runden schon oft gemacht, mit von Verwaltung, von Wirtschaft, von sonst irgendwo, was denn nicht so Daten wären, die spannend sind, die man öffnen sollte
wir hatten noch nie so eine Runde mit mit so vielen genialen Einfällen wie dort, weil die Jugendlichen halt ganz klar so, ja, ich will eigentlich das wissen und das wissen und wieso kann ich nicht erfahren, wie mein Lehrer meine Noten berechnet? Und ich will wissen, wie gut oder schlecht meine Schule ist
und alle möglichen Bereiche hauptsächlich Bildung aber dann noch andere,
ähm Gesellschaftsbereiche, wo sie halt einfach ganz konkrete Wünsche hatten, so, ja, ich will das wissen.
Und äh so im Nachgang zu diesem Jugendakt werden wir uns auch diese ganzen Wünsche.
Äh mitnehmen und da mal mit ein paar von diesen Jugendlichen uns einen Ministeriumstermin besorgen und dann.
Bisschen lobbyieren, dass beim nächsten Jugendtag in Österreich zweitausendfünfzehn wir dann hoffentlich schon ein paar von diesen Daten haben.
Alles im Wesentlichen so Webanwendungen oder Apps oder beides.
Ähm war hauptsächlich Web und Android.
Hatten auch äh so IOS-Entwickler dabei, aber da gab's irgendwie bei den Jugendlichen ähm recht wenig.
Ähm Gefühle für, also die waren eher so auf Android. Das waren auch viele, die äh eher so aus der Java, Zep Plus Plus Pfeifenwelt kam
Äh und jetzt äh wenig objektiv sie ähm aber ja so eher in dem Bereich.
Ja, da kann man wahrscheinlich auch die Politiker mal fragen, warum sie für ihre letzte äh Miniatur App, die eigentlich kaum was macht, wahrscheinlich eine halbe Million rausgeschmissen haben, während hier sowas irgendwie von einem Vierzehnjährigen an einem Wochenender entwickelt wird.
Das könnte man auch nochmal fragen.
Schönes Ding, also ähm mir war das vorher gar nicht klar, dass die äh dass das eine Open Knowledge Foundation in Österreich gibt. Ist die denn direkt verwandt mit der Open Knowledge Foundation in Deutschland oder ist das nur Namensvetterschaft?
Nee, nee, äh also
Da kann man auch noch mal drüber reden, ob ein Knowledge äh Foundation ist so ähm gab's die erste in Großbritannien, äh die nennen wir inzwischen Central äh und es gibt äh wahnsinnig viele lokale Chapter, fast überall auf der Welt. Ähm
also auch äh jetzt nicht nur in den westlichen Ländern, sondern eben auch in in Indien, in Afrika, in Lateinamerika.
Und da ist auch wahnsinnig viel Bewegung drinnen, also dieser dieser Bereich hat.
Irrsinnig viel Anklang gefunden, überall auf der Welt und ähm die ähm die Deutschen und die Österreicher kooperieren da natürlich sehr stark. Man geht auch irgendwie auf die auf dieselben Veranstaltungen und eben es gibt so Projekte, die einfach,
gut funktioniert haben und die importiert man dann natürlich auch. Also das Jugend hakt ist ja eigentlich auch
nach einem Vorbild aus Großbritannien, äh das hieß dort äh. Ähm ist aber mehr oder weniger dasselbe Konzept, was dann äh sehr cool umgesetzt wurde von den Deutschen. Und und dann haben die Österreicher halt auch gleich wieder.
Und äh das äh die die Foundation ist auch so als Informationspol und als Anlaufstelle auf jeden Fall eine Adresse, die man immer empfehlen kann
äh von der Ausrichtung her sind die Deutschen und die Österreicher ein bisschen anders, aber ähm an sich ist der Kernstock und die Message und die Aufgabe die selbe.
Und äh weißt du eigentlich, ob's das auch in der Schweiz gibt? Schon?
Hm, nein? Nein? Äh also ich ich mag Gott, doch, doch. Also ob neulich Foundation Schweiz müsste es schon geben.
Lass mich schnell schauen OK verweist auf Punkt CH.
Äh ja und das ist das Swiss Chapter of the Open Knowledge Foundation. Also scheint's auch irgendwie da zu geben.
Na, ich habe so den Eindruck, wir müssen demnächst hier sowieso nochmal einen kleinen Schweizfokus äh einrichten, dann werden wir das dann mal entsprechend erforschen.
Ja, damit kommen wir zum äh letzten Teil unserer äh Sendung und das ist der beschwingte Teil.
War unsere Termine.
Ja und es geht äh in dieser Woche bald wieder los und zwar vom dreiundzwanzigsten bis zum sechsundzwanzigsten Oktober in Hannover findet statt.
Over vom CCC Hannover, ein Wochenende frohen Hackens. Wer Lust hat, sich solchen Hackergemeinschaften mal äh etwas näher anzuschließen und entspannt ein wenig rumzuhacken.
Bietet das den richtigen Platz.
Und am fünfundzwanzigsten Oktober um zwanzig Uhr findet die Big Brother Awards Gala statt. Und zwar im Rabenhof Theater in Wien im Gemeindebau. Einlass neunzehn Uhr, Beginn zwanzig Uhr, Eintritt frei, aber.
Angeraten.
Vierundzwanzigsten Oktober findet der CSU-Netzkongress statt, inklusive Staatssekretärin Dorothea Behr und zwar im BMW-Welt-Doppelkegel in München.
Na da bist du doch eigentlich für jeden was dabei sein.
Also Netzkongress klingt natürlich total interessant, ne? Schon lange auf keinem mehr. Ja, ich bin gespannt, was denen da so alles einfällt.
Thomas. Vielen Dank für dein äh abermaligen Besuch und Beitrag hier äh bei Lokbuch Netzpolitik und viel Erfolg vor allem mit äh AKV in äh Österreich.
Und.
An alle anderen, sag mal winke winke, tschüss, bis bald, das war's äh die hundertneunzehnte Ausgabe und ich hoffe, nächstes nächste Woche geht's wieder weiter mit Linos.
Bis bald.
Bis bald, tschüss.
Tschüss.